hi I'm Eric Voss and Godzilla king of
the monsters was the surprise hit
trailer from comic-con this year
seriously who expected a religious
experience from a Godzilla reboot sequel
the whole time this thing is filled with
monsters and Titans I mean so let's go
through this trailer frame by frame and
point out all the details that you might
have missed what these creatures are and
how this movie will connect with its
2014 predecessor and everything else in
this monster burst at Titan verse also
this video was sponsored by Dollar Shave
Club stick around to the end for details
about an exclusive offer just for you
guys
spoiler warning in case any of my
predictions end up being right and let's
get started our world is changing the
mass extinction we feared has already
begun we ok these opening few seconds
introduce us to Madison Russell played
by Milly Bobby Brown Bobby who of course
plays 11 in stranger things stitching
from this trailer might as well be the
same kid facing off against a massive
creature with long parts Madison is a
daughter of dr. Emma Russell played by
Vera for Amiga we hear her voice here
and throughout this trailer Emma is a
paleo biologist working for monarch that
was the organization from the previous
movie but the mother and daughter have
been kidnapped by another mysterious
organization more on that in a bit now
if you're wondering where this is this
is Boston you can see the Prudential
Tower in the background there and the
whole thing just smells like Sam Adams
behind Madison is a US flag along with
APO WMI a flag now that's for the
National League of families for
prisoners of war and servicemembers
missing in combat it flies on six
holidays throughout the year suggesting
this scene could be taking place on
Independence Day or Memorial Day or
perhaps the people this world are just
wanted to honor soldiers who have gone
mi a during these kaiju wars the flags
shift direction signaling a shock wave
from a coming cloud more on this in the
next clip
are the infection
[Music]
and as Madison takes cover we hear Emma
explain in her speech that the planet is
facing an extinction level event and
that human beings are the infection from
Riga has described this movie as partly
a mission to save the environment and
from our speech it sounds like this
calamity was brought on by human
activity now this has always been part
of the traditional origin of Godzilla
which in the original Toho films by
director Ichiro Honda in the 50s
featured the monster getting awakened
and empowered by nuclear radiation the
whole character was conceived as a
metaphor for nuclear weapons now this
trailer doesn't specify exactly what
kind of human activity brought on all
the different monsters but I have a
theory that we'll get to later let's
move on the earth unleashed a fever to
fight this infection its original and
rightful rulers the Titans okay probably
the most powerful element of this
trailer is of course the music
this is clair de lune by claude WC it's
one of the most famous compositions from
the Romantic period it's really one of
the best songs to evoke natural beauty
and splendor but it has been used a lot
of different ways in a lot of different
movies like an atonement it was paired
with wartime imagery in the purge it was
ironically paired with a montage of
human savagery in Ocean's eleven it was
paired with a feeling of release that
victory brings along and twilight
eclipse it was used because Claire de
Lune literally translates to moonlight
deep and here Claire de Lune works
really well to express the natural
beauty of the kaiju so that rather than
beasts to be feared
they're godlike Titans meant to evoke aw
Emma makes her speech through a video
feed encouraging humanity that they use
all the Titans to eliminate the threat
or to do what Ken Watanabe suggested in
the previous film that don't fight and
listen to the way Emma talks about the
Titans The Cure she says Mother Nature
gave them to fight their own infection
its original
and rightful rulers now this is some
pretty radical language here at least a
little more extreme than a rational
scientist concerned about human life and
collateral damage would say but her
delivery of this is a little stilted as
if it's being recited I don't know it's
just worth considering that maybe Emma
is being forced to read the speech
against her will maybe this organization
that kidnapped her and Madison are
threatening in mine too reading their
own psychotic manifesto hoping that this
scientist will lend that some authority
we also meet more of the cast Kyle
Chandler coach Taylor as Emma's
ex-husband mark and Bradley Whitford as
the scientist dr. Stanley he's joining
mark on a mission to rescue Emma and
Madison along with Ken Watanabe
returning from the previous film as dr.
ish Shiro Serizawa he's in a submarine
as it explores this undersea cave and
noticed the hieroglyphics on the walls
now these are ancient markings
describing the existence of titans from
ages past
now we actually got a glimpse of these
hieroglyphics in the post-credits scene
of Kong Skull Island which mentioned the
monarch company
so yeah these movies are connected in
case you didn't know Warner is gearing
up for a big crossover movie Godzilla
vs. Kong in 2020 yeah versus big stuff
verse let's move on the Titans for
thousands of years these creatures have
remained in hiding around the world
here we see more of the rescue team
there's O'Shea Jackson jr. from Straight
Outta Compton playing Barnes he leads a
military group working with monarch
called the G team they bring soldiers
into battles involving the Titans and as
Mark observes Godzilla underwater with
this three bladed scales funneling the
beams of light very cool we see Thomas
Middleditch from Silicon Valley he plays
Sam Coleman hit communications liaison
between mark and the government there's
also Sally Hawkins reprising her role as
dr. Vivian Graham from the previous film
and you know what she wants to do with
this undersea creature talk to it she
she just wants to talk to movie night
and unless all the Titans are found our
planet will perish and so will we
they are the only guarantee that life
will carry out okay big stuff here Emma
and gaze up at a giant block of ice and
they're joined by Charles dance Tywin
Lannister from Game of Thrones he's a
great moment later on in the trailer I
assume he's running this mysterious
other corporation that kidnapped them
the ice contains another famous Godzilla
monster King Ghidorah you can see it's
three serpent heads in the ice their
Ghidorah originated from the Toho film
Ghidorah the three-headed monster
initially it was believed that Ghidorah
was a metaphor for the growing threat of
China to Japan which developed nuclear
weapons in the 60s but the director said
it was just a modern take on the dragon
Yamata no Orochi it's a Hydra like
dragon with eight heads and eight tails
Emma's voiceover explains that all the
monsters need to be found and this
trailer shows is for Godzilla King
Ghidorah Mothra and Rodan this movie has
an interesting promotional website for
the monarch corporation allows you to
circle a globe for locations of the
other Titans including currently
classified ones around Cambodia and
Australia Morocco Sudan Egypt another
one nearby in the Middle East and then
in Austria and Scotland and eastern
Russia and in the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean and in the US somewhere near
Atlanta then up in Canada and then down
near the Grand Canyon in Baja Mexico the
map also shows Godzilla tracking his way
along the water there there's another
location in the South Pacific presumably
this refers to Skull Island which we
know has its own Titan the Declassified
locations give us more details about the
Titans that we see in this trailer
Ghidorah is frozen all the way down in
Antarctica and it is referred to as
monster 0 suggesting it was the oldest
of the known Titans Theodora is
historically an evil monster at least
compared to Godzilla who's kind of a
chaotic neutral like he doesn't really
care what he destroys and definitely
compared to Mothra who's definitely a
gentle giant Ghidorah is the
arch-nemesis to these two he can fly and
his massive size causes gravitational
shifts seismic activity tidal waves and
cyclones and he carries a bio electric
currents in his body I meant him to spew
lightning and start electric storms so
seeing it frozen on the edge of
Antarctica brings me to that theory that
I mentioned earlier perhaps the
environmental calamity that they were
referring to is global warming which we
do know is causing the ice caps to melt
and break off at rapid rates maybe now
the melting ice is awakening Ghidorah
the
titin so now they have to awaken the
rest of the Titans around the world to
bring him down one of the other
locations of the monarch map is deep in
the rain forests of the Yunnan Province
of China which contains Mothra that's
what we see here in this waterfall the
site says Mothra is still in a pupil
stage pre hatching Emma brings Madison
here allowing the girl to touch the
creatures nose fermitas said that emma
has figured out a way to communicate
with the creatures and potentially
control them using bio acoustics on a
sonar level I don't really know what all
that means sound waves but I'm thinking
there could be some kind of telepathic
link between these women and Mothra
actually in the Touhou films Mothra is
often joined by twin priestesses the
shop gym there these little fairies who
dance and sing for Mothra kind of
serving as a translator from opera to
humanity it's awesome I don't know I
could see this movie adapting that whole
idea of Mothra priestesses with these
two women who seemed like they could
share a sensory link with the giant
creature let me know your thoughts in
that theory on to the next clip
[Music]
whoo money shots so joining Marc in the
boat is Jiang Zi as dr. chin and I just
love when Godzilla fires his atomic
blast up of the sky his bladed scales
illuminate - and we see that same kind
of bioluminescence with Mothra as she
opens her wings now this light can be
weaponized in a blinding destructive
blast that's called God rays what we're
looking at here could be the moment she
actually hatches and unfolds her wings
it's super appropriate for these two
Titans to share the to power notes of
Claire de Lune
back to back Godzilla's often called the
king of the monsters but mater is called
the queen of the monsters so even though
we don't see the king and the queen team
up in any one frame in this trailer the
editing and the music and the lighting
bringing them together very well done
let's move on
you are out of your goddamn minds I am
sorry but this is the only way
okay here there's a shot of Emma back at
that icy Antarctica station with
Ghidorah and in the background you could
see Madison once again reaching out with
her hand looking closely at Emma's
terminal screen as she pushes a button
it says detecting specimen bioacoustics
maybe there's something to this
telepathic connection with Madison maybe
there's something about Madison that
triggers the bio acoustic response in a
kaiju
we also jump to a new location this is
Isla de Moana in Mexico it's a volcanic
island and the resting place of the
fourth Titan Rodin Rodin skin is
comprised of volcanic sediment collected
from centuries of dormancy in magma so
Rodin is based on the Pteranodon it's
Japanese name is actually a contraction
for the word Pteranodon the way Godzilla
represented the lingering nuclear fears
from the United States to Japan Rodin
represented the nuclear threat from the
Soviet Union where Dan was one of the
earlier kaiju in the Toho movies after
Godzilla
he actually got his own movie earlier on
and he later showed up in the Ghidorah
movie that I mentioned here you could
see the shadow of what I assume is Rodin
flying over a city low enough to tear
the Roos off his wings can actually
create sonic booms and he gets to some
shots of Madison running down this hall
as massive blasts of electricity
pulverized the place now I assume this
is from Ghidorah as remember he can spit
electrical charges but where is this
well look at those images on the wall
those are old-timey baseball photographs
now we know Madison is in Boston at some
point from those earlier shots and in
this section we see another shot of a
truck smashing through a gate with a
radiation sign that says Boston so I
think a good guess is that maybe she's
in Benway Park here the twisted debris
that we see her surrounded by later in
the trailer definitely looks like it
could be part of that structure it's I
don't know I guess good news Yankee fans
moving on
[Music]
[Applause]
in this section we see Madison in this
office sadly looking at this photo of
her family on this iPad now a few
seconds later we see this same photo but
framed on a table in a house as it
quakes notice how there's an older
brother in this photo that we don't see
anywhere else in the trailer perhaps
we're seeing what caused this family to
split up perhaps a kaiju attack that
resulted in the death of Madison's older
brother and the grief being too much
maybe for Mark and Emma to bear also
notice that number 31 on the desk
earlier we saw number 32 outside the
Antarctica's station perhaps these
numbers correspond to the monarch
stations around the world which they
number for every new dormant I do that
they discover there's also a shot of
Rodin soaring over a wrecked Washington
DC no I suspect those cyclones and the
lightning were actually caused by King
Ghidorah and after Madison cost someone
a monster another shot frames are with a
Titan right outside the window if you
look closely you can see a second head
in the background there so this is
definitely a Ghidorah and it's really
the one good look we get its face in
this trailer moving on to this final
part
long live the king
okay after Rodin deals with some fighter
jets we get this glorious master shot of
Ghidorah silhouetted and fog followed by
Charles dances great line long live the
king this is an obvious nod to Game of
Thrones has Tywin Lannister
II saw multiple kings die and probably
had to say long live for all of them we
also see Rodin clap his wings perhaps to
omit his sonic boom and dr. Serizawa in
a volcanic eruption probably on a
mission to awaken Rodin and the final
shot shows Madison smiling up at
Godzilla who definitely looks like he's
on the side of the good guys with the
squadron of military aircraft coming in
like cavalry behind him but a question I
have for you guys which are the four
Titans that we see in this trailer do
you identify as your spirit kaiju are
you a gentle giant like Mothra are you a
clumsy badass who doesn't care what he
breaks like Godzilla or are you an icy
moody jerk with a split personality me
Rodan all the way baby I want to sleep
in a volcano for thousands of years it
was so warm and just like Clapp away my
enemies
beat it kids cutting in line at
Universal Studios comment down below
with your thoughts or tweet me directly
at ei vas and follow new rock stars on
Twitter for updates on her videos this
video was sponsored by Dollar Shave Club
look we all have our everyday grooming
routines sometimes that morning breath
is atomic you got a brush and you know
you got to do something with this well I
bet you didn't know the Dollar Shave
Club yes that Dollar Shave Club has all
of your grooming products toothpaste
body wash hair styling products
everything you need to look feel and
smell your best and nobody are they
covered this much it's the drugstore I
wish existed check it out you get all
this stuff and this calming body
cleanser it's perfect for when the
haters heckle you on twitter too the
Comic Con trailer breakdowns are takin
too long
Dollar Shave Club is basically giving
away their daily essentials starter set
to new members for only 5 bucks this
starter set features three trial sized
versions of their most popular products
to help you stay fresh and clean along
with their executive razor in your first
box who received their shave butter body
wash and one wipe Charlies butt wipes
you'll also receive their executive
razor which includes their premium
weighty handle and full cassette of
cartridges after the first box
replacement cartridges are sent for only
a few bucks a month this $5 offer is
available at dollarshaveclub.com slash
new rock stars that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash new rockstars
get on this guy's have really helped
support this channel and like this video
share it around and subscribe to new
rock stars for breakdowns in an hour
of all the stuff that you love and all
the big stuff to come out of Comic Con
thanks for watching